The key to D3's magic is in the selection before the data binding,
the data binding itself, and the selection after the data has been bound,
in this case the .enter selection, which is actually a very special type
of select which we then eventually add shapes or
circles, SVG, or HTML to our page for every element in this enter selection.
Many tutorials out there gloss over this detail of what exactly is the enter,
at least to start off.
But I think once you have a solid understanding of the data join,
these selections that come after data join, much of the rest of the library,
d3 that is, and the complexities involved with adding interaction and
animation to your graphic fall into place quite nicely.
Mike Bostock, the creator of d3, has one of the best posts on the subject,
not surprisingly, and it's titled Thinking with Joins.
I'll take a short diversion to explain what a join actually is and
what it means in the context of d3.